[Music]
who's a fan
of shia labeouf me yeah
yeah you were in what way
like i i appreciate him as an artist
yeah
i think he's a great artist yes he is go
with that i don't want to be his friend
yes yes so yeah so he's always had like
uh on a personal side of things right
he's always got
like a lot of personal issues that's
kind of followed him throughout his
career
and uh if you guys remember i don't know
if you guys saw saw honeyboy
it was like uh his his own like almost
like a biopic
and he played his own father and he kind
of uh outlined the kind of made me
respect him a lot seeing that movie
true i understand them like like to a
certain degree right okay yes that's a
better word that's a better one write
that down
honey it's really good you should watch
it he plays his own dad in his own
biopic
where um he outlines like the kind of
abuse
that he endured as a kid as a child star
even stevens yeah it shows like when he
was acting
what about the other movie where he
played like a gangster or like a mob
mob guy what movie is that are you just
writing a movie
david ayer and i had to forget the name
of the movie but i heard it didn't do
too well though
it's already out yeah he came out when
he got the huge thing there's such a
random question
of a [ __ ] i thought he made it up too i
was like what he did play that
[ __ ] yeah he plays like an
assassin or something like a hitman
like a but like don't get sucked into
his hole
no but he he he was convincing because
to me he's always the transformers boy
right
yeah so i think the panicking guy that
likes the girl
and then i'm like for him to like become
like this mob boss that was believable
in my mind i'm like [ __ ] he's a good
apple watch even stevens
no for me he's always been like that
[ __ ]
creepers steven generation yeah so i had
always seen them that way so they're
watching honeyboy and then seeing like
the behind the scenes version of it i
was like oh
you went through all that it kind of
breaks your heart a little bit yeah
so um because if anyone's seen that
movie it kind of outlines the kind of
background he has and so in his current
like you know adult life he you know has
had a lot of episodes with law
enforcement
uh episodes with himself and like trying
to
understand why he is the way he is and
also alcohol problems
alcohol problems yeah do you guys
remember the the when he did the whole
like
art installation thing or like a
performance art thing where he was just
kind of sitting at a table and you get
to talk [ __ ] or do whatever you want
yeah yeah yeah he just kind of takes it
when he wore a bag over his face
yeah was that the same thing i don't
know wait why did he do that it was
because of breakdown or something
happened right where he felt like he
deserved
that type of yeah after he stole content
or some [ __ ] like that like he
there's so much he's been involved yeah
he's he's got a storied past
is that that's how we'll put it so the
latest thing that happened
this uh star all started in december
um do you guys know who do you guys know
fka twigs
yes she used to do robert
yeah twilight guy yeah twilight guy well
she is uh that's an interesting name
and uh twigs huh yes i thought you were
talking about pattinson you're like
that's a weird name
pattinson she was in honeyboy too
she is yeah she so they met on the set
of honeyboy i'm assuming
but um they dated for a little while and
now she's following lawsuits against him
for
sexual abuse abuse and
basically all sorts of abuse that's some
abusive [ __ ]
and some abusive [ __ ] and shia labeouf
shanna buff
so abusive so that's december
in the time from december to now he's
gotten with another girl named margaret
quality
and i actually don't know how to say her
last name quality quality
quality quality let me give you some
quality
pictures to look at so this is shia
labeouf i know what he looks like
this is margaret ooh she's like a
classic oh is she an actress
she's an actress that royal show
yeah yeah she looks like it maybe like
the crown is she in the crowd
i know she looks like she belongs in the
crown
but like maybe as a maid not the royal
girl right
you know where he's seen her she's in um
once upon a time in hollywood
oh the girl in the corner that gets
picked up by brad pitt all the time the
hippie girl yeah hippie girl yeah
yeah at the bus stop she's the feet the
feet yeah she's the feet
yeah and then that's them two together
so they started dating
now amidst the allegations made against
shia
she's decided to dump him because she
is placing char not charges but she's
basically um
who's that that's suing him suing him
yeah doing him yeah this is fka twigs
and this is fka twigs and shia together
now
there's a joint uh lawsuit against shia
too now because of
fka twigs and even the previous
um girlfriend which is some asian chick
not a celebrity
um but they're filing some joint [ __ ]
against shia now
about him being an [ __ ] and you could
sue people for being [ __ ]
or like emotional emotional abuse and
sexual abuse and
all sorts of things so uh what fka twigs
was um that's why i was like yeah i
think i am
no i don't know like he's so he's so
controversial in his personal life
we're like [ __ ] but we like them for the
artists we don't like them for them we
don't know that i don't know him i don't
know about any of this stuff
the reason why i was like i don't know
is because with the whole fka twigs part
of it
he did come out and like acknowledge and
he's like yeah i was [ __ ] up like i'm
so sorry i did that to her
and all this other stuff so i'm like
he's
changing right oh yeah he's on the way
but yeah i don't think he's good yet
he's trying well he's just my girlfriend
broke up with him because of the lawsuit
or like it's bad publicity so basically
from i think i think from a professional
standpoint it's like if you're not
if you're involved with shia labeouf
you're going to be dragged into his
[ __ ]
and for your career that tells me she
didn't love him
yeah they're probably just new right
they're very new very very
like not worthy the love wasn't intense
enough
well their love is pretty intense in a
music video that they start in it's a
not safe for work so if you're
interested in seeing some is this one
called
some very sexy music video shots of
margaret
with shia labeouf whose music video is
this uh
[Laughter]
different artist it's actually mark with
margaret's sister's music video
i want to know what what like kind of
[ __ ] they got into
not because like um like
i don't know if it happened or not but i
just want to know like the details
it sounds crazy because i don't like
whenever you see people right
you don't go yeah he [ __ ] his
girlfriend up
you never know right right like do you
guys see a human being and go
that's a wife beater right there
sometimes depends on what they look like
it does depend i mean because i do when
i see a person i'm like he looks like a
pedophile
you know what i mean like oh true he has
that look you know what i mean what's
the wife beating type
that's what i'm saying is unless you
have a mustard stain
on your tank top and you're always
holding a beer and your hair is like
[ __ ] up and then you're like yelling
at women it's hard to be like
he's a life beater or it's hard not to
say that you mean
no no it's hard to identify one because
there is no like
stereotype look unless like that there's
that trailer part guy like you know that
oh he looks like that type hollywood
trope yeah the trope
it's like when you but anybody could be
one like
like the dad at the park just playing
with his kids
he could be a wife beater yeah or like
you just don't [ __ ] know true like
how serial killers are
or it could be really handsome and
attractive you never suspect
yeah yeah yeah i promise i'm not a
serial killer i think you're a good guy
that's stupid all right so that music
video is called love me like you hate me
by rainsford and that's
margaret's sister [ __ ] me like you hate
me oh [ __ ]
maybe maybe that's probably what shyla
buff was perfect for the role because
he'd be like
loving girls like he hates them
true so at this point it's so abusive
so according to the lawsuit uh fka
twigs is um citing accusing him of
physically mentally and emotionally
abusing her during the relationship
and uh but did he pay for any of the
meals
i don't know maybe not but according to
one incident
uh he would drive car the car recklessly
and uh removing his seatbelt and
threatening to crash unless she
professed
her love for him like some drama [ __ ]
yeah he's just korean
and then uh i think i love you more than
you love me you need to you need to say
you love me
we're also gonna crash this car some
heavy ass [ __ ] man another instance
uh he woke her up in the middle of the
night choking her
i actually light hand she he laid hands
on her in this instance and then another
time
the actor assaulted her at the gas
station stop
after she begged to be let out of the
car pulling over
uh he threw her bags out the car and
throwing her against the car
while screaming in her face and then
forced her back into the car
so it's just a lot of like i hate you i
love you i hate you i love you
at very intense loud i wonder if there
was like
gas station footage yeah i don't know
because they could have sold that [ __ ]
to [ __ ] tmz for lots of money
true i'm fine i know right yeah well
another aspect to this story too it's so
it
a lot of it has to tie back into the
industry that they're in and like their
work life
so shia met margaret
during this music video shoot and this
music video shoot was directed by
olivia wilde do we know who olivia wilde
is all right so olivia wilde
just recently casted shya in one of her
upcoming movies and now she's
transitioning into being a director
cool now according to
uh her and some of olivia wilde's team
members
shia didn't like the the editing of the
music video
and requested his own cut and he
actually did the editing himself and
submitted that
and then email response olivia wilde's
like
that's cool i'll check it out but yeah
i'm going to submit my version i'm
director you know
and you know film industry there's a
hierarchy and you know she's hired to
direct and to kind of see through the
vision yeah that's what she's going to
do yeah
shia on the other hand responded to that
email saying that's the wrong answer
you should be you should know when as a
jazz player you should know when to not
play and that was his response via email
to olivia wilde and then she's like i'm
playing classical music [ __ ] i know
yeah conductor [ __ ] take your
own advice
exactly and then sit your triangle ass
down [ __ ]
you're the maraca player right now no
more cowbell i don't
you're like the tambourine player like
shut the [ __ ] up
you ain't even the guitarist man yeah
and the final straw was the fact that
she is on olivia wilde's new movie
and she still used them well this is
where he
she drops his ass uh when she when he
shows up for
pre-production like a table reader
sometimes why am i not thinking
uh uh uh yeah a production meeting a
table read or whatever
uh he somehow acted out a line and
she cites that she has a changing she
has a zero [ __ ] policy and she fired
him on the spot
and then hired her new boyfriend this is
all like harry smith harry styles yeah
this is all like literally
hollywood romance problems yeah
isn't it funny how like when they don't
take things
personal like uh they just don't they
just
let [ __ ] go wild it's like i don't give
a [ __ ] i'm gonna work with this person
they can give me views
whatever and then they go oh well but
it's bad publicity right now i don't
need them anymore i'ma just move over to
someone else
i'm like damn dude i would be so
stressed out because i am so prideful
like i can't work with this [ __ ]
and then it's like oh this guy said this
to me i want to slap him so bad i want
to fire him
but they really bite their tongue and
just keep moving true
they're like well he's good yeah we just
finished this movie we'll get them on
we'll make some millions go to the next
one really i feel like in the industry a
lot of them are very spiteful
like certain directors will not work
with certain people certain
yeah it's like that's very gonna work in
this town again yeah
true you get blacklisted really quickly
a lot of people just [ __ ] sucking it
the [ __ ] up at night
that's why the me too [ __ ] is blowing up
now you know true
like a lot of if there's dollars to be
made right so like i think shia labeouf
at the end of the day he's he's
lucrative you can you can make money off
it's like that and that's why their
eagles run [ __ ] wild because they're
like
trying to tell the director now this is
the way to do it because they've
you know gotten away with it yeah man i
didn't know it was like that yeah he
needs help man i feel bad for him like
i'm not
obviously everything he's doing is
[ __ ] atrocious and horrifying but
like
people like him need help and i hope he
gets it he did go
to like how honeyboy came about is
because he was in
uh what was it like he was
institutionalized and
he had his like his therapist had him
just start
journaling his life and that's how he
came out with the script for honeyboy
what are we gonna accept that crazy
people create the best content
that's true the best artists are usually
the most broken people in the world
they want like these like well-tamed
self-aware
artists and i'm like ah guys i don't
know if we can have both
it doesn't exist but it's not like we
can't allow them to do what they're
gonna do but i'm just saying man like
sometimes [ __ ] batshit crazy people
well you kind of have to be crazy to see
[ __ ] in a different light you know
yeah it's just when they become harmful
we gotta put them in the cage that's all
that's all i'm saying
shout out about make a movie and then
throw them back in the cage
that's pretty much like probably
[Music]
happening
[Music]
[Music]
foreign